hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about mail merge in excel
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn
now first up what exactly is mail merge
mail merge in excel is a simple yet
spectacular method to write similar
emails to hundreds and thousands of
recipients without a hassle or even a
single error
let us imagine that you are supposed to
write an interview call letter to
multiple recipients
so
what if you had like five recipes you
could do five different emails and you
could send them but what if you had 50
or even 500
right that would seem a little
troublesome and you might even feel that
you might want a whole team to do that
right but what if i say that you can do
the same with one single male within a
matter of minutes you send all the
emails to all the 50 or 500 recipients
sounds interesting right so now in this
particular tutorial we are going to do
the same
now without further ado let's directly
get onto the practical mode and start
our excel and try to do some mail merge
in excel
now we are on practical mode and we have
started our microsoft excel
so
regarding the example we discussed
earlier that is sending an interview
call letter to multiple people that's
what exactly this excel sheet does so
here we have about 25 members or 25
candidates with their first name last
name and email and their address written
over
now where is our call letter now this
happens to be our call letter so the
call letter has been sent from an
imaginary company that is smart
solutions private limited india
and followed by that we are having one
recipient here who happens to be mia
and the subject and everything all the
text related to the interview call
now we are trying to send this one
single interview call letter to all the
25 people
now the only change that is going to
happen is the recipient's name and
address is going to change and the
addressing for example here you can see
dear mia so instead of dear mia we're
going to greet the recipient with their
particular name so that's what we're
going to try to do now so to do that you
have to go into the toolbar and select
mailings option
in the mailings option you can see
the start mail merge select recipients
edit recipient and all other options so
here you might want to select the second
group and inside the second group you
have an option called select recipients
click on that and now it will show you
some options the first one is type a new
list so if you are having some list then
you can type in or if you already have
an existing list like what we did
creating an excel sheet and storing all
the email and address and all the
recipients complete details you can use
that as well
so here we're going to use the existing
list so click on that
now it will show you a new dialog box
using which you have to navigate to the
existing list
so our existing list is named as mail
merge so click on that and select open
now press ok
now the next part is to address all the
details
so here
you can see that
two address and after that you can see
the addressing of the recipient now we
have to encode this mail in such a way
that to all the recipients automatically
excel will replace the addresses names
and the greetings right now let's try
that
now let's try to encode the address part
so highlight the address part and in the
same mail links option
you can find
the
address block in write and insert fields
ribbon
so let's select that
and now you can see the address of
everyone
right
so this is the preview of the
recipient's address now you can see that
the recipient's full name and state is
only available here not the street and
house number etc now you can fix that by
selecting the match fields option
and here you can include the address
so
which might be the house department and
the second one would be street
and
postal code you can match it with pin
code
and that's all yeah remaining we have
everything else let's look at the
preview and this is how it looks like
perfect
now let's select okay
that's fine
and
similarly we will also try to
match the
just a moment yeah similarly we'll try
to encode the recipient's name
now for that let's go into the greetings
line
here you can see you can select the
option
dear sir or dear ma'am or to whomever
mates may concern
and here you have another option
to or just dear so we'll go with deer
and this is how the preview looks like
and if you're happy with that
it's okay and if you want to parallely
check for other things i mean other
recipients you can also do that
for example the next recipient is santo
shastri and followed by him we have
prabhakar reddy rajesh sahoo right you
can also check everything and here you
can also see the address changing on the
mail
so we can check for jagadi's chari his
address and his name
right so it looks like it's working
perfectly now select ok and that's done
now we are in the final stage and in the
mailings option you can see the last two
options that is the preview results and
finish so before merging and finishing
the mail merge we shall go through a
quick preview to check if everything is
fine or not
so here you can see we have the address
block this is how the encoding looks
like
and if you
replace the encoding with the actual
address and name this is how the actual
address name look like and you can check
all the letters you can just click on
the arrow key here and you can check all
the recipients address and their
names
right so if you can find any errors you
can replace them and if not if
everything is fine then you can just
quickly press on the finish and merge
option when you finish merge option or
finish and merge option you get three
different
options that is edit individual
documents print documents and send all
these to the recipients
now if you had any queries or if you had
any doubts about or if you find any
errors on the emails then you can go to
that particular individual document and
edit it with the first option and in the
second option you can print all the
documents like if you want to send a
hard copy then you can print it
so you can see here all and select ok
and then you can
you know kind of save it as a pdf or you
can
send the location of your printer and
then just press ok
right you can just save them in the form
of pdf
or you can directly send the emails
right now i'm not connected to any
printer so i'm not going to print any
documents now let us try the last one
this should be interesting
now when you select the mail option
then it automatically selects the email
column
from your excel sheet remember we had an
email column from excel sheet right
this particular column word
automatically selects that column from
excel and you can just select ok and all
the mails will be sent to all these
imaginary mailing addresses
so that's how it's done now with that we
have come to an end on this tutorial on
mail merge in excel if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you feel
that we missed out on anything important
then please let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to resort all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here